hello hello how long you guys been
sitting here um a little bit did you
guys see what happened um so I actually
talked to the girl because so when we
got here they were over the bar by the
car like fighting up and who's they um
her well they weren't like fighting
physically they were just having like a
a yelling like an argument like a right
vo vocal alter verbal verbal yeah that
one um and so sorry I'm like shaking
cuzz I'm really cold and I was like
talking to her so like but um they were
like over there arguing by the car she's
like filming him and then filming
herself and she's like laughing and like
I don't know it just seems like she's
like not like right at the moment I mean
from like what I can tell um so I you
know I like walked over cuz then she
started so she started following him
around when he started to call the CPS
and she's running after him with the
video recorder and so I started filming
on my phone because she's like running
after him and I know if she like touches
him and stuff like I know that's like
harassment and like stuff and so she's
like chasing him all around all around
putting the flashlight in his face and
all that and she gets over here and I
see them like kind of like he's like
trying to run away from her kind of and
she's like grabbing on his shirt and
stuff okay and so that's when I was like
oh no cuz we're all over here and they
were o over there like just him on the
phone and she's like chasing after him
so I walked over and I know her so I I
said her name and I was like Hey Selena
like whatever and I was like it's you
know me like can I like have a
conversation with you or whatever like
trying to like deescalate things cuz
she's running after him yelling at him
and like he's on the phone with the
police and like I don't really know what
happened like at the like I got here
when they were yelling at each other so
like I don't really know what happened
before that and I was like you doing
this is making you seem like you're in
the wrong like you need to stop like it
just needs to be calm and like you wait
until the cops get here whatever
whatever and I have the whole
conversation on on camera and she's like
grabbing me and getting in my face and
like calling me up this stuff like y at
me and stuff and so like then she put
her hands on me I was like don't touch
me like I don't want you to touch me or
whatever and she wasn't like physically
like harming me or anything just you
could tell she was kind of like oh my
God like what's happening she was like
he's trying to do this so that I can
like he can get my money or whatever and
like all this stuff and I was like I I
don't think he would get the cops
involved like you know if he's trying to
do that like trying to like calm her
down at least until you guys got here so
she could like actually speak to you
instead of like being like freaking out
like she was um but that's that's so you
just saw them on fo up yes and then I
saw them going over there so I went
after them when I saw everyone coming
over here going on tell me what's going
on cuz I didn't want to be alone like
standing by her or whatever go over
there come over here I'm like I'm just
going to get my car and sit in my
car did did you see at any point her
driving that car no so when I got here
the other girl was in the driver's seat
what other girl um there's two so
there's the one in the the white shirt
uh-huh that's Anna no you don't know who
she is there's Selena and there's the
other one I guess which one's in the
white shirt is that Selena yes and then
the one in the black
hoodie yes so I don't and I know that
she was saying how she kept recording
herself and she was like I hit him with
my car like it was me saying that like
she gave him her information and all
this
stuff and then he was like I don't need
your information you weren't driving
like I just need her information like it
can be done or whatever and she's got
like the camera in his face like you
know doing like taunting him almost like
saying like you know do these people
have anything to do with this um so not
I don't think so I kind of like
obviously like this whole thing is like
going on so we're all kind of just like
whoa what's going on okay but so there's
a female over there with blonde hair
with a white shirt with red paint all
over yes so that's Selena that's Selena
yeah come walk over here is that paint
or it's it's a CL it's a all right let's
come over here
he's literally flying on my name like
for real he's trying to be a fish for no
reason like yes I H my car a while back
and I didn't say anything about it
because shit it was whatever highspeed
chases we got up unruly suspects I will
kill that mother me no do it stay in the
Box I like K dramatic DUI I'mma pass
everything that she trying to do and
shocking body cam footage hey get on the
ground get on the ground law and crime
presents body cam the place for real raw
and wild police videos you should have
seen it it was good it's on body camera
I'll show it to you catch the action and
subscribe to our new YouTube channel
now it's none of their business what
happened in my car before and yes
somebody was sitting in my car but they
they weren't driving on the road it is
not in my business he's literally lying
and saying I hit him he has no proof he
has video of whatever the fuck he was
recording but I swear to God please come
here I swear to God he was not how old
are you I'm 20 you're 20 yes I know I
don't look 20 why have you been drinking
because it's Halloween and he's been
drinking too it's not Halloween I know
it's not Halloween but I've been
drinking because they had a party and
it's not what's the legal age of
drinking 21 and I understand that and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
regardless it does matter yes but it
doesn't matter cuz I've done it are you
yes I am okay the I
say no he's lying cuz he wants so it's
her C here back up over there it's her
car right here ly he's lying he's not
lying yes he is I saw the he lying about
how he got it there's no proof of how he
got it I didn't run him over that's just
why where car at it's over there yes
there is damage my car that doesn't mean
that that happened onto him where is
that your car yes that that car is mine
but there's other cars here and there
was a if you look up on the whatever
search you have there was a fat party on
the other side of there and then right
over from there they came all the way to
here there has been many of cars here it
doesn't matter
I did not run him over it doesn't matter
he has no proof of it and I did not do
it like I did not do it and he's just
saying that he the reason why I'm saying
he has no proof of it is because he was
videoing me saying I have proof of
you yes I do how do you know him be from
past from past experience in high school
and he's literally sh me in my face and
everyone else was just out doing it
because another guy just trying to get
with me tonight I rejected him and all
this just doing way too much over that
didn't have I don't even know but all I
know is I didn't hit him that's it okay
and I know that and the owners why I'm
crying like this is because I know it
didn't I should not get it for I didn't
do and I don't give a if my car is has
damage to it or not and I never reported
it it doesn't matter what my car has to
it it matters I didn't hit him and that
is all that I know and he had recorded
whatever the he recorded but he didn't
record the fact that I HTE him cuz I
didn't hit him and I know that I didn't
hit him all he recorded someone in my
driver's seat and him recording my
license plate which at first I wasn't
letting him record cuz I didn't do it
but then you know what I was like you
know what if I have nothing to hide I'm
going to let him record it so I let him
record it and I said what did I do and I
questioned him what did I do how did I
hurt you how did I hurt you he wouldn't
answer how I hurt him it doesn't matter
what
he says in certain situations and little
parts of the situation he didn't explain
the whole entire situation and that's
what's happening okay and it's making me
scared cuz this can affect my future for
something I didn't do and you know this
and I didn't do anything and all the
fact that all these clout ass people are
sitting here backing him up cuz I don't
know them like that hurts me as well
especially cuz I don't know them and
they're obviously going a backup people
that they know over someone they don't
my name's Nina Nina Selena Selena that's
my legal
name yes oh can I please at least cuz
I'm can I Le get a little dabed cuz no
one else has ever spelled those so okay
so Selena yes
mhm big issue here yes
okay I think all of this could have been
avoided mhm had you not been underage
drinking yes you're
right okay so I don't know the rest of
what's going on they're going to start
pcing together everything that's going
on is it what happens if they find out
that he's lying from underage drinking
and just trying to get
money I have
noide
okay but that's why we got to conduct
our investigation we've got to figure
all this out and then go from there okay
okay so in the meantime just relax take
it easy we're going to figure this all
out okay okay well I'd like to stay with
you it's
really I'm sorry I
look professional by this place saying
this for money it's so fucked up I don't
even know how to react to something like
this cuz I mean it's understandable but
it's not understandable because I
understand his perspective but I don't
understand his
perspective he knows me was literally
the whole night sorry your
phone
like I said they're just trying to
figure it all out right
now understand where is the other person
who accused me of this accusation I
don't
know you go to college nope I just got
out of high school and all of these
people are still in high school from
what I
know you got of high school at 20 huh
when didd you get out of high school
like last year you said you're 20 yes I
went to
school and all these kids are still in
high school I don't know honestly it was
a really big party before and afterwards
it was just like a couple few people
which I knew a couple of them from from
high school and he was already from
drama like honestly he was starting
drama that I was settling before with a
previous which is a friend from before
he was like starting Dr with you get
over here we okay so there was like a
was in the car with you no there was a
party from over there and they shut that
down and then we came over here and
there's a whole bunch of people over
here here and yeah and then afterwards
the cops were still over there and we
were over here they didn't ever came
over here and then there was like a
whole bunch of people over here and he
was starting drama with other people and
then I left because I was in it for
little a little bit but I wasn't like
the one who started it he like called me
like a bitch and then my friend looked
at him like who the you calling a bitch
obviously he was being protective I was
like yo chill out and then I left and
then they kept going at it and then my
friend was being mature enough to handle
it and be like yo it's my fault I'm
sorry left he kept going at it my friend
came back said yo I'm sorry he his his
ego was like too much for him to expect
or ECT any situation that was going on
so we kept going it on and then after
that we kept going it on we all killed
for a little bit we left we came back
and then next thing I know he's over
here accusing me of freaking hitting his
car cuz he's problematic as no proof of
it he's just saying it because he wants
money for some reason I asked him in the
video what did I what did I hurt how did
I hurt you this and that this and that
he wouldn't answer the questions in the
video he was just s here and recording
me say you hurt me this Blood this Blood
it doesn't matter how the blood happened
we've been literally sitting here for
months I'm not for months for weeks I
mean not for weeks I'm drunk I'm sorry
like that like I'm drunk like so
obviously we were sitting it for hours
so we've been back and forth over there
and there and so shit happens and I
don't know how the that happened I was
not the reason that happened and there's
no proof on that video that it was and I
know for a fact I was not the reason
that happened so there's no proof on
that video so when I asked him he
couldn't give me the freaking proof and
he kept recording me asking for the
people who was with me for
information and that's all that happened
and that's why it scares me cuz no
matter
what accusation like
that like that's an accusation that's my
future I have so much for my future I
have so much I I don't go out like that
my credit as high as I'm going for my
shit for my life and he's I don't know
what the's going in his life what are
you trying to do with your life I'm
trying to be a businesswoman I'm trying
to be shit I don't go out I try to do me
and try to build myself as someone
beautiful and what you trying to do with
business where do you work right now um
I do like nothing really special at
first I was doing freaking an auto last
thing I'm trying to get in freaking
um doing what's the word I'm
sorry I'm trying to work with myself I'm
trying to be in real estate I'm trying
to get in real estate number three right
now I'm working as getting my lessons
for real estate and cleaning and shit
like that and I don't go out like that
and right now I went out for a little
bit cuz it's a freaking holiday and it
but it's whatever I don't care and I'm
not a holiday it's almost a holiday and
I know it's not a holiday but I don't
even like to go out when most people
it's not even a holiday it is almost
holiday cele it's almost a holiday and I
don't like to go out when it's a holiday
because there's much more
people just
sit can you explain what's going on to
me because I know he's lying to whatever
he's saying and I don't I whatever I as
much as you can explain
as much as she can I can explain to you
it'll explain what she to me she's
now still missing a lot of the pieces
she's going over there to talk to our
supervisor exactly try and figure
everything out they have not been able
to express or talk to each other was to
connect the dogs to each other to be
able to make it sound completely
understandable before they decided to
call the cops because it doesn't make
sense as doesn't you know what I mean
yeah exactly nuts tripping like it
literally I knew it I knew there and I
knew it and I said it to him and I have
it on my phone but unfortunately I have
no idea where I dropped it so it's
either the person who has my car keys or
the to be
honest it's one of those but I'm sure
I'll find it
soon honestly I know that at the end of
the day I know that I didn't do anything
wrong wrong and if I do get something
wrong it's going to happen either way so
except whatever I get wrong or whatever
I get in trouble for even if I didn't do
anything wrong because whatever happens
fucking
happens and all of those people when I
was literally there recording him as
soon as I started recording and they
acted so different they started
obviously you know how they started
acting they start acting like oh we
don't want the drama we don't want the
cops we don't want the okay so why
didn't you want that before when I
didn't record anything now you don't
want the drama of the cops because I'm
showing you and I'm showing the cops in
the video what's going on is that like I
know that's a lot of package on you
right now no not on me I'm just saying
right now that is a lot of package on
you can tell by the way you're
stretching your uniform
um okay so what happened tonight so
tonight I came back here looking for my
phone which
was in my car and this guy decided to um
I don't even know to say make fun of me
because my car was already broken or
technically broken if you want to say
that before I even got here he wanted to
make fun of me there's video and his fun
proof of it oh haha you you're fucking
car is broken hahaa okay that's so funny
I decided to snapch this pH cuz it's
obviously not funny to me and yes that
wasn't very highly of me I'm going to
have you walk over here with me actually
um okay so right now I'm going to be
honest with you okay um I'm conducting a
crash investigation okay so um you're
the registered a little lower cuz I feel
very aggressive when you're talking no
cap I'm sorry that's not you feel like
I'm being aggressive just when you're
just I'm just saying like the way talk I
just want to make sure it's clear yes
yes more calmer please Okay Okay cool so
um right here walk over your car oh
thank you I like the way you're talking
right now okay good pleas feel more
comfortable ma'am how did that happen
Okay um I have hit a pole before you
what I hit a pole before where's that
it's not illegal to hit a pole I
understand that okay what pole did you
hit a pole a while back over there okay
okay walk with me over here I want to
show you
something the fact that we're coming in
over here whatever just watch your step
yeah it's a little
Sandy so like I said I'm I'm just I know
I'm trying to talk karma for you um I'm
conducting a crash investigation right
now so we have um a eyewitness that said
you hit a I didn't hit anything over
here so whatever they're saying is line
okay I just want to show you
anyway
sure wearing this outfit and I've been
that the whole oh my God the fight that
we coming this far funny what here H
it's one of these do you see any sents
anything yes you see right here right
here no I did not hit that pole okay
were you parked over here at any point
no no I swear to God I was not if
there's any cameras it would prove it I
did not park anywhere near here and that
is okay I parked over there that's where
I sat at that moment okay so you're
saying the other girl who is completely
sober is is lying she I don't know what
the fuck they're saying but I did not
Park here and I did not move where I
parked is where I where I stayed what
was your first name again my name is
Selena Selena I'm I'm you're not in any
trouble okay like I said and I'm not
lying or anything I know where I parked
and that's where I parked period no no
no I'm not worried about parking but and
I didn't hit anything over here I went
over there how' you get over there if
you pulled in that way how' you how'd
you get in did you loop around yeah I
looped around like okay so you did come
around here yes okay cuz you you said
you didn't at first and I wouldn't go no
I didn't I just said I didn't hit that
okay all
right how old are you Selena I'm 20 in 3
months okay all
right
I'm I'll try and get you out of here as
soon as I can yes I understand I'm not
pring
any so um I just wanted to let you know
right now um my crash investigation's
done okay yes like I said we have a
wheel witness that puts you behind the
wheel of hitting the pole okay I know
you said you didn't okay and I'll will
document that your statements but right
now I'm switching hats into a DUI
investigation driving Under the
Influence okay all right so were you
operating a vehicle tonight um I was I
was operating a vehicle tonight no I did
not crash this vehicle at that place
where you showed me I did not I did not
cross that vehicle and they did come
over here and make fun of me for the
vehicle that was
hit before and it's very inappropriate
and I feel offended but what it's
whatever like they want to sit there and
sit there and like oh my God you hit me
I'm sorry but that's kind if you think
about it like for real you think about
it right if someone imagine somebody
accusing you of doing that okay um so
when when at what point did you have
your uh your drink so you you drove here
I've been drinking from a long time
you've been drinking all day not all day
okay what time do you think you started
drinking I don't know
like I don't
know because
what
time I don't know I really don't know
but it wasn't all day for sure it was
not all
day um just give me an estimate of it
was night time it was night night it was
night um where where did you start
drinking your friends um
well I was
here and a lot of people came it was
over there for a little bit but then
right when I got there right when I got
there the cops came there and then we
left and we came here so right when I
got there I was drinking a little bit
but it wasn't like a lot at all it was
like one Sip and then I came here and
then that's when I start dring and
that's it okay so let me just make sure
I get this clear you you didn't start
here you ended here correct no I drank
here like I drank here and then I stayed
here okay where were you before here on
the other side oh on the other side okay
then that's when the cops came yes so
you drove back over here and then you
started drinking here again yes okay all
right so how many how many drinks did
you have over
there on the other side not even a
really a shot because the cups were like
coming at us because there's a lot of
cars there okay a lot so you think like
maybe one shot not even like a shot okay
what what what was it a shot of like a
little sip like of what
um um it was a I think fuck I forgot to
be honest cuz I'm drunk right now so I'm
I forgot what it was but it was the same
thing I drank all night which I forgot
what I will remember later but
um okay I'm trying to remember right now
hold on okay no problem take a time oh
Crown Crown Crown okay one sip one tiny
sip of crown and then I came over here
because the cops were
like and then everybody was like
scattering and and I was like oh and
just people were running all over the
streets so I was trying to get out of
there and then I came over here okay we
want to thank Morgan and Morgan for
sponsoring this body cam video I mean I
think it's pretty clear from the body
cams that we cover that it's not always
safe out there when you're hurt it can
be confusing it can be scary you don't
really know where to turn well Morgan
and Morgan is actually the largest
injury law firm in America and in a time
when you already have so much to think
about they're going to make it super
easy for you they have completely
modernize the process because you submit
your claim you sign contracts you upload
documents you talk to your whole legal
Team all on your phone that's it an
attorney is going to review your case in
just eight clicks also they have 4,000
support staff that can help you too
which is just amazing to think about and
in terms of price well you only pay them
if you win there's no upfront fee so if
you're injured and you want to join the
over 3 million people that call them
every year you can submit a claim at
www. forthepeople.com
LC body cam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone it was L
you know right you know and then that's
when I started drinking cuz nobody was
over here and the same people that were
here all night were literally here all
night and he he had already gotten
arguments two times okay with some other
people and he was Mak cuz he called
somebody a bitch wa well honestly that's
somebody was me but he called somebody a
bitch and it was me and and then he the
person what if which one of when you
guys got into a fight were you on your
way home is that why here yeah yeah yeah
so um when you were you in okay let me
try and get this question correct you
were in the vehicle correct and you got
out and started fighting no we were out
of the vehicle okay at what point did
you start arguing with uh Kane I don't
remember it was a really it was like a
an a couple hours ago all I know is he
started arguing with me he was being did
you get in the car cuz you were upset no
I never got in the car okay the thing
was is that he was calling me a bitch
and my friend looked at him like who are
you disrespecting like that that is rude
and then my and he was being so over
dramatic he was
like I'm sorry I'm not TR I'm just
trying to like explain he was like and I
was
like chill and he was
like and obviously I'm trying to be the
person cuz my friend honestly my friend
was playing cuz my friend and I were
really close and so I was like bro like
who you call to bitch cuz and my friend
was coming up right when that and so I
was like bro my friend's going to say
something to you and then my friend when
I said what you mean he was like he was
like oh what you me and I was like oh he
called you a bitch and then he was
like so I'm going to ask you one more
time okay
so since you've been drinking at this
spot I know you did say you were on the
other side and you had a sip of Crown
Royal and then you came drove it back
over here and then you started drink
some more mhm at that any point Sorry I
mean too much no no no I'm just trying
to make sure I get everything straight
for my report purposes okay um you don't
want too much yeah yeah yeah so when you
came in where did you park when you came
in from the other side on that side oh
you parked on this side okay how'd your
car get over there if you don't want me
asking I went on that side I I'm not on
side oh so you weren't on this side yeah
I'm not out side can you point and
instead of just yeah so you were
originally on this side yes okay so you
did not park on this side like you told
me twice no I told you that side okay
the first time okay did Paris up you
honestly I didn't even tell you that I
went anywhere I just with the crash yes
okay so we roll with the D what's that
roll with the signal one yep all right I
already told her I'm I'm conducting that
right now I'm going to do the test right
now okay um did Paris already update you
on the other one yeah yeah so okay we're
going to do this one first then we're
going to talk to her and just do another
crash or whatever okay do you have uh
tape in your car by chance of course
okay of course I do I know right um I'm
actually going to have
you okay this get the best light it's
going to stink like with the the the
flashlight actually come over here it
might be better under these lights if
you don't mind walking over here with
me see if we can get under some street
lights there we go this is much
better all
right so what I'm going to have you do
is just stand with your feet together
arms down by your side okay and just put
your head straight and look at me okay
all right so I'm going to have you look
at the tip of this pen all right just
with your eyes I'm going to move it side
to side all right you're just going to
follow it with your eyes do not move
your head do you understand mhm
okay
okay he's going to be right back with
some tape okay all right cool
you can stay right here though oh I
thought you wanted me to stay here yeah
you can stand there that's
okay go ahead your phone
yeah nice tag Mr 104 huh nice tag Mr
104 what's
up you I have the pee
okay oh I didn't know that cuz I have
the pee and I am 20 almost 21 I'm sorry
but peeing is not something you can win
but can you guys unlock the door you
guys like
have oh okay cuz yeah we're doing uh
fsts right now I have no
idea okay all right I'll will talk to
him thanks e my shoes are literally so
ugly so um I was going to take short
videos of your
um test the test but you already did the
HDM yeah yeah yeah no that's uh that was
that was six out of six um I'm gonna go
talk to Paris real quick six out of oh
thank
God where where is
Paris
oh
do you um do you have the booklet with
the instruction yeah okay in my car grab
it huh there's like
oh
to go that way I'm if you get your phone
I'll record it your body can
no what TR trust me trust me trust me um
where's your ax on no your a on perfect
so I'm going to record
it record it so it be when like get
specific you just pull up as aut video
how are they allowed over here in the
specific position like that's
not that's not cool yeah they're going
away we're making sure that
17 301 the female that was running from
vehic a white Mercedes or can
[Music]
you when you can face me now yeah yes
yeah okay so um while I just explain the
instructions you want me to walk the
line and make sure I don't have a DUI
pretty much right can I explain the
directions okay just stand with your
feet together down hands down by your
side while explain the instructions okay
yes it's so cold can you do please do it
quick like I'm not used to this weather
this just newest F so oh you're not from
here no no I am from here I'm not used
to it being this cold all the time cuz I
am from here okay so what I'm going to
explain the instructions and then I'm
going to do a little demonstration for
you I'll make it as quick as possible I
do a demonstration I've done it in high
school okay well I need to go through
this okay for my policy all right so
you're going to do not do it until I say
okay all right you're going to put place
your left foot on the line then place
your right foot on the line ahead of
your left what it's going to look like
yes this line this is going to be the
line right here okay so like I said
you're going to place your left foot on
the line all right right foot in front
yes okay mhm you don't have to do it yet
okay I'm just you can face me so you can
all
right um while doing so you're going to
have the heel of your right foot touch
your left foot okay the top of your left
foot okay yeah um and you're going to
keep your arms down at your side all
right just like this okay can you sit in
that position for me why explain the
rest of
instructions okay do not funny I thought
you said they were going to
leave Hey cuz this is not funny them
they've been making fun of me the whole
night this is just place your arms I'm
by your side okay we're we're going to
make sure okay do not start until I tell
you to do so okay and it's distract in
me because I'm listening to them and
it's not
appropriate and the whole thing is
distracting
me oh it's literally distracting me
as see do you see what I'm saying like
this
is like the reason why they like exact
reason I wasting
way I'm not doing anything what am I
doing let
me' I'm so cold just a little bit longer
just get damn jacket
but all right
so I'm going to continue okay go ahead
and stand in the position like I told
you to do so okay can stand by your side
what's your what's your idea
1929 when I tell you to begin you're
going to take nine Heel To Toe steps on
the line I'll demonstrate in just a
moment okay yeah can I please
get I'm sorry I'm we're almost done okay
just please yep okay so like I said she
should take all right like this arms are
okay yeah now place them down by your
side okay mhm so I'm going to say it
again when I tell you to beginning
you're going to take nine heel toe steps
on the line okay so what it's going to
look like you're going to do it on the
line I'm going to do it right here so
you can see me
okay
do do you understand I do need a jacket
for I'm cold as fuck and I'm we're
almost done ma'am can you stand in the
again yes okay you're going to keep your
arms down your side at all times watch
your feet and count each step out loud
just as I did once walking begins do not
stop until you've completed the test do
like this that's what you want me to do
do you need me to explain the
instructions again I'm just asking if
that's the kind of turn you want like
just like I demonstrated that's the kind
of turn I okay um do you understand the
instructions yes
you may you may
begin you done mhm
okay just
put no that's good so I can go back yep
no you're right you're
right I know right like expected all
right put her in the starting POS one
more all right one more
yep all
right you no no no no you're not doing
this exercise one more other exercise
okay you're going to stand there with
your feet together arms down by your
side
okay maintain that position until you're
told otherwise okay when I tell you to
do so I want you to raise one leg either
leg with the rais foot approximately 6
in off of the ground hly don't know how
much keeping you can estimate okay I'm
going to demonstrate can you demonstrate
okay I'm going to demonstrate just this
would be so much easier if I had a
fucking jacket I'm sorry I'm just so
cold this is the last exercise
okay I'm sorry I cannot do it like this
I'm cold as hell just one more yes I'm
going to do like this I'm
s when I tell you to do so I want you to
raise one leg either leg with the raised
foot approximately 6 in off the ground
I'm going to demonstrate keeping the
raised foot parallel to the ground both
legs straight and with both arms down at
your side okay you can do that for now
but when I want you when you start okay
arms down by your side you're going to
look at the elevated foot and count out
loud in the manner of one 1,1 1,002 13
and so on until told to stop can I ask
good question the fact that I need a
jacket and I'm freaking cold I cannot
we're almost done ma'am I cannot on
anything else do you understand the
instructions yes I am cold okay so I'm
going to demonstrate it okay so fact
that I'm cold doesn't matter to you
ma'am we're almost done okay I'm going
to get you let you get a jacket right
after this okay all right like this okay
1001 1,2
134 1005 1006 1007 start the start okay
do you understand the instructions okay
you may start 1001 1002 1003 1004 1005
10078 1009 110 okay what the fuck is
after
that all right
um You can stop that
thanks all right do you have a coat in
your car yes all right let's go get get
coat I do not have my keys somebody else
has my keys who has your keys man I
don't know somebody else has my keys so
what are we doing with cuz one of us has
to she's over the she's over she's 20 so
yeah so um so right here do I have a DUI
or no ma'am that's
all honestly I'm not trying to be
disrespectful you got to do another
cross investigation right here then you
have to do have a county come out since
she's a minor and do a PBT oh so I'm
doing both of them can I ask you a
question why the fuck are these other
people who are
lying so Paris calls you over for
nothing I have no idea for nothing I
love that
[Music]
Merc go ha to
Paris um I'm going to have you walk over
my vehicle okay all right can you take
your arms out of your shirt for me
yes
just place your hands behind your back
okay behind your back yes are you
putting me under arrest yes ma'am for du
don't I do not have don't resist all
right I'm why do I have I'll explain to
you
okay ask yeah so you um you admitted to
me over there that you were drinking and
driving and then we have a wheel witness
and you failed the fsts all right so we
have reason to believe that you are
driving under the influence of alcohol
all right so you under arrest oh my can
I at least get my phone where is your
phone well will I be able to it yeah
it'll go it can go to the jail there
okay where is it I want to jail where is
it oh my God it's like girl my car is
literally parking nowhere can you least
park it in the in the parking lot yeah
yeah where are your keys it's what
girl whatever girl I need you to sit in
the car first where is your
phone it's I don't know I'm pretty sure
it's with the girl but I'm not sure if
it was dropped on the floor okay I'll
ask her once and for the keys in the
phone and if she doesn't not give them
to me I can't do anything okay can you
sit in the car I'm going to try I'm
saying if you do get the keys can you
please put them in they're going to go
with you yeah yeah yeah I'll park the
car and then give you the keys yes thank
you
yep wait how long does the bu stay on my
record I'll explain that in just a bit
okay sit
[Applause]
tight gagnan does she have the keys for
the
vehicle does she have her phone as
well
there's no 10 three or anything right
[Applause]
okay she gave us permission to move the
vehicle will you just pull it up real
quick to where just put it in a spot not
in the middle of
a
yeah yeah she's gonna move
uh what's that I I think those are spot
oh I don't know I would just probably
pull it up to the pegs the
wooden does she have two phones on her
Paul this girl yeah uh I think
so yeah she said she had
it I hope
that's I mean I can ask her where the
background is if you want is that what
you're worried about no it's just I
asked for her mom's number and that
looks like the pH she P out her mom
call M she has two phones they could
look Alik
yeah yeah she did this one so that's uh
she was the last one to
drive yeah well either way she aded it
so I
mean no no no this one behind
me oh no I didn't ask that actually can
definitely do that if you'd
like
yeah um Gail before I
go um do you want to ask my 1017 any
questions regarding the crash because
she was in the
vehicle uh regarding that crash cuz
you're doing a crash investigation right
now right yeah okay if you want to ask
mine before I'll take the keys Bud
than I'll roll in the
[Applause]
window what's your name
Selena
[Music]
sh get yep and it's moved into the spot
okay this is your phone right M okay
yeah you'll be able to make a phone
call no um you make a phone call um
after processing okay so listen to
officer listen to this officer wait I
feel comfortable with you I'm here so
she was never driving the car no so how
did we get to that what are you talking
about we have a wheel witness who is
right there in that car wait what are
you talking about so she never did
anything never this is your car I I did
everything whatever is in that car is
me okay
um
this is a that's the
PBT okay you want me to stay
um
okay just give me one second
okay yep you'll be able to I'm going to
ask you to step out really quick CU I'm
going to search you and then we'll get
going okay of course you can search me
there's no I need to search yeah just
it's quick going to be equip pack down
since you don't have anything on you
really you don't have anything piece of
paper did you even search them or
anything did you did you do what you did
to me for them can I ask you that or
no or
no did you or not what's that CH them or
make them do what you did to me what did
they
do they called you for a saying I
insulted them for no reason it's that
one okay two of them
thanks you okay all right I'm going to
get the seat belt on just give me one
second to put it around
you this is really embarrassing and fact
because the fact that they're lying
about a lot of shit that and you are
literally giving in no no you have to
slide over here slide back over there
I'm just getting the seat belts
ready
I didn't want to reach around you why I
even wait can you before you shut the
door like every other time you do can
you please explain to me how this
letting me out of jail goes letting you
out so tomorrow you'll be able to um get
out all right tomorrow yeah what if I
try to get out before with my family
yeah how much will it be I'm not sure I
I can I I'll tell you when we get there
okay it'll be quicker when we get there
okay all right sit tight